the Raiders versus the Patriots our guys
Chandler Jones with the game winning
that's former recovery I don't know what
you call that man you call it a
touchdown Game Center touchdown fifth on
Mac Jones stay up going to the end zone
arms out with the hero Pro I'm sitting
on the couch bro like I yell like oh oh
he stayed up I'm like hey he gonna go
down I'm like he's gonna try to trip him
he stayed up say oh yeah
that's what you want Bros Edge Russia's
dog you wanna you wanna end the game bro
then you have your whole sideline come
you know
fans throwing stuff at you in a good way
it was another crazy game the largest
wildest comeback in NFL history the
Vikings versus the Colts I think the
Vikings are down 33 points you know I'm
sitting there watching the game in real
time and all the things that that coach
Saturday was doing like he did
everything for his team to win I just
think from a momentum standpoint that
the Vikings just had it like right when
they got 21 points and they started
feeling like okay we can win this game
the Colts went up 23-0 at one point I
remember looking at my brother I was
like man if I can come back and then
boom let's just slowly start doing this
and then like you said bro once you get
that momentum you just find ways to win
those games like that and then once that
crowd start clapping it's over with man